keeping it really dialed in and sticking
to what we do best so we have our
initiatives are I where we have our
branded product Muscat originals and
Moscow spirit we have our eye care
initiatives where we provide
comprehensive I hear my phone is by at
and so it's important that we a very
transparent tell you exactly what we're
doing and connect with a distinct
audience that really appreciates what we
do yeah for us again it was really
sticking to our brand integrity but I
think sunglasses in general are a very
accessible accessory because at you're
able to really have that the brand
plaque if you will on your face for a
lot less than it would be to get the
suit or the the handbag or so forth you
can buy a proud of pair of sunglasses
for a few hundred dollars but you can't
not this the same person couldn't maybe
have access to the handbag or the shoes
so sunglasses are huge and they're very
defining its I would say one of the most
defining elements that someone can can
have as a fashion accessory I like to
make a the ante blink so you know it's
it's very timeless its style over
fashion it's not-it's no branding
externally on our product it's very true
to the original intent of the eyeglass
frame it's all based on our archives and
so forth so that's how that's how we
position ourselves we don't need to
broadcast who we are on our frames we
let this style precede the brand so to
speak
not doing it soon expect nothing but in
terms of you know I've been pretty
methodical about it I know glaring
mistakes come to mind I think maybe so
at moments being overconfident but I
would say that would be kind of the
mindset I try to put myself in every day
so we'll see